네 안녕하세요 어 제가 오랜만에
스튜디오에 왔습니다 기존에 빌사남이
간다 이제 실내 촬영을 좀 많이
했는데 좀 요즘 트렌드라지만 시장
상황이라든지 뭐 이런 생생할 정보를
알려 드리도록 하겠습니다 결론부터
얘기하자면 빌딩 거래량은 상승했지만
임대 시장은 좋지 않습니다 그래서
상반기 데이터를 보면은 작년과
비교했을 때 거래량이 좀 많이
늘어났어요 특히 2분기 같은 경우에는
작년 거래량보다 거의 한 두 배 정도
거래량이 상승했습니다 그래서 그만큼
거래량이 좀 많이 상승했는데 그
상승한 이유 중에 가장 큰게 바로
금리가 내려왔어요 뭐 한 2분기
때까지만 해도 빌딩 담보 대출로
만약에 뭐 대출을 좀 빌리면 금리가
한 5%대 막 6%대 이렇게
나왔습니다 지금 올해 같은 경우에는
한 2분기 때 뭐 4% 적게는 뭐
3% 때까지 내려가면서 금리가 좀
많이 내려갔어요 그로 인해서 빌딩
거래량이 좀 많이 상승했습니다 그리고
지금 하반기 같은 경우에도 거래량이
좀 많이 늘어났어요 아마 작년과
비교해서 거래량이 뭐 1.5배 많이
면 한 두 배 정도는 더 늘어날
것으로 좀 예상이 됩니다 1등 같은
경우에는 금리와 영향력이 굉장히 크기
때문에 금리가 내려갈수록 거래량이 더
상승합니다 그거와 반에 임대 시장은
좀 좋지 않아요 그래서 제가 그
데이터를 보니까 지난해에 폐업률이 한
10% 정도 된다라고 합니다 그리고
소매업이 이런 음식점 같은 경우에는
폐업률이 20% 아지 올라가고 그리고
신규 창업했는데 폐업하는 율이 한
80%지 늘어났다고 합니다 열 곳을
창업하면 한 여덟 곳이 문이 닿는
거예요 자영업자들이 매우
어려워졌습니다 그래서 뭐 인건비가
올라가기도 했고 재료비가 많이
올라가면서 임대 시장은 좀 좋지
않습니다 지금 최근에 기업들이나 이런
곳에서 신규 투자 유치가 좀 되게
어려워졌어요 21년도 하더라도 신규
투자 유치라는 뭐 이런 걸 너무 많이
받아서 사무실을 막 확장하거나 이런
경우가 많았는데 최근에는 이런 신규
투자 유치가 없어지면서 오히려 규모를
더 줄이고 있습니다 이러면서 오피스
공실률도 되게 높아지고 있어요 그래서
강남을 예로 들자면 이런 테 난로의
프라임급 빌딩들은 공실률이 그렇게
높지 않습니다 근데 그거와 반해서 그
이면에 있는 꼬마 빌딩 같은 경우에는
공실률이 되게 높아졌어요 근데 언론
기사를 보면 대부분 다이 프라임급
빌딩 기준으로 이제 기사를 좀 많이
냈습니다 그래서 뭐 공실률이 역대
최저다 뭐 이런 얘기를 많이 하긴
하는데 실제로 거기 이면에 프라임급
빌딩이 아닌 이런 작은 빌딩 같은
경우에는 공실률이 되게 많이
높아졌습니다 그래서 좀 정리를
해보자면 거래량은 늘어났지만 뭐 임대
시장은 좋지 않다네 이렇게 보시면 될
거 같습니다 그리고 제가 매각사례 두
가지를 말씀을 드릴 건데 아마 이제
접목해서 보시면 될 거 같아요 그래서
둘 다 강남권의 매각 사례고 한권
같은 경우에는 22년도 80억 원을
매입을 했습니다 호환기 때 80억
원에 매입한 다음에 시장이 제일 안
좋았을 때 80억에 72억 팔았는데
그냥 8억 만 손해 보는게 아니라
취득 관련 비용이라든지 금융
비용이라든지 이런 거 다 포함하면
거의 10억 넘게 손해를 받습니다
근데 그거를 매입하고 나서 임대차
만기가 올해 5월까지 만기 있는데
지금 10월인데 불구하고 아직까지
임대가 안 되고 있습니다네 그래서 그
정도로 지금 임대 시장이 좋지 않아요
그리고 두 번째 사례 같은 경우에도
노년 동의 매각 사례인데 22년도
10 3억에 매각된 사례입니다 지금
거의 2년이 지났는데 아직까지 임대가
안 되고 있어요 그래서 진짜 21년도
그때까지만 해도 진짜 임대 시장이
너무 좋았는데 22년도 하반기 때부터
금리가 많이 오르기
시작하면서 임대 시장이 매우 안
좋았습니다이 두 가지 사례를 통해서
아무리 강남이 좀 이렇게 손해 보고
매각될 수도 있구나 그리고 아무리
강남이 이렇게 임대가 안 될 수
있구나 뭐이 사례를 통해서 알 수
있습니다 뭐 사례 얘기하면서 좀
말씀드리면 그 저희 스터디가 지금
8년 동안 하면서 수많은 건물주들을
만들어냈어요 진짜 한 몇 천 명 정도
수강을 했었고 그제 몇백 명 정도
이제 저희가 건물주 분들을 만들어
드렸고 저희 스터디를 수강하면 가장
큰 혜택이 어벤져스 팀을 만들어
드립니다 그래서 뭐 중개사 만 아니라
설계사 그다음에 시공사 그리고 은행
그리고 법무사 뭐 변호사라는 세무사는
빌딩과 관련된 사람을 다 연결해
드립니다 그리고 심지어 무료입니다
그래서 스터디 수강생 몇 기지만
얘기해 주시면은 저희가 다 무료
상담이 가능합니다 사실 이게 물어볼
데가 없잖아요 뭐 설계라는 시공 비
견적서를 받았는데 견적서가 많이
나오는 건지 적게 나온 건지 알 수가
없습니다 저희 건설사 대표님한테
충분히 물어볼 수 있기 때문에
스터디를 통해서 이런 어벤져스급
전문가를 저희가 소개해 드립니다
그리고 저희가 현장 답사를 합니다네
번에 답사를 진행하고 강의뿐만 아니라
이런 생생한 현장에서들을 수 있는
그런 답사도 포함하고 있으니까 이런
네트워크를 좀 형성할 수 있어요 그
빌딩을 하나를 보더라도 다 각자마다
의견이나 이런게 좀 다르기 때문에
이런 네트 워크를 형성할 수
있다라는게 우리 스터디의 가장 큰
장점이지 않나 이렇게 생각합니다 요즘
좀 트렌드를 보면은 빌딩 거래되는게
다 좋은 위치에 있는 건물이라는 진짜
급매 위주로 빌딩 거래가 좀 많이
일어나고 있습니다 그래서 저희가 막
21년도 때는 진짜 막 다 팔렸나요
그런 시기가 아니라 정말 좀 괜찮은
위치에 괜찮은 가격에 건물들만 거래가
되고 있다라고 보시면 될 거 같고
그리고 임대 같은 경우에도 진짜 좋은
위치 뭐 진짜 임대 의 가격을 매우
낮춘 아니면 렌트 프리를 엄청 많이
준 그런 빌딩들만 임대가 되고 있어요
그래서 실제로 저희가 강남권에 저희가
통임대 임대를 마쳤습니다 그래서 그
건물 같은 경우에도 렌트 프리를 무려
6개월이나 줬어요 심지어 인테리어
비용까지 지원했습니다 정말 임차인
모시기가 쉽지 않습니다 그렇게까지
해야지 지금 임대가 되는 어 그런
시장이라고 보시면 될 거 같아요 근데
반대로 구정 로데오 메인이라는 뭐
성수동 뭐 연무장길 메인이라는 뭐
대치동 학원과 메인 거리라는 이런
건물들은 진짜 임대가 너무 잘 돼요
그거와 반해서 뭐 임대 시장이나 매매
시장도 이런 격차가 좀 많이 일어나지
않나네 이렇게 생각을 합니다 여러분이
만약에 이제 뭐 앞으로 빌딩을
매입하거나 뭐 빌딩에 이제 인대를
진행한다고 하시면 이런 전략을 좀 잘
세우실 필요가 있는 거 같습니다 아마
코로나 때부터 빌딩을 보신 분들도
계실 거예요 근데 그때 생각은 아예
접어둬야 될 것 같습니다 그러니까
그때 는 사실 말도 안 되는
시장이었고 진짜 기준 금리가 0%
대가 뭐 지금 한국 역사상 그런 적이
없잖아요 그리고 앞으로도 그렇게 되긴
쉽지 않을 것 같습니다 빌딩을 만약에
앞으로 보신다고 하면 가격이 좋거나
아니면 진짜 건물 연면적이 되게
크거나 수익률만 보는게 아니라
보수적으로 보셔야 될 것 같습니다
임대 시세도 예전에 저희가 코로나 때
막 비싸게 맞췄던 어 그런 임대
수준이 아니라 진짜 현실적으로 얼마에
마칠 수 있는지를 정말 보수적으로
보고 판단을 하셔야지 실수를 줄일 수
있다라고 생각합니다 내년 같은
경우에도 금리가 내려갈 것으로 좀
예상이 되기 때문에 거래량은 좀 계속
늘어날 거 같아요 근데 임대 시장은
계속 좋지 않을 것 같습니다
자영업자분들이 금리가 뭐 당장
내려갔다 그래서 당장 이렇게 영향이
있거나 그렇진 않아요 어 제가 봤을
때는 최소 뭐 1년 이상은 지나야지
그때부터 조금 좋아지지 않을까 이렇게
예상을 하는데 어떻게 임대를 마칠지
좀 포인트를 가지고 어 투자를
하셨으면 좋 좋겠습니다 대출 같은
경우에도 금리가 뭐 내려갈 것 같긴
하지만 저는 무리하게 받는 걸 좀
권하지 않아요 그래서 뭐 최근에 막
이렇게 영상 같은 거 보면 뭐 진짜
풀대출 받아서 실투자금 없이 막
투자를 했다 뭐 이런 광고들이 되게
많은데 그거 진짜 너무 위험한 겁니다
대출 많이 받아서 잘못되는 경우 너무
많이 받기 때문에 현금이 총 매매가
대비해서 뭐 30% 아니면 진짜
50% 정도는 최소 가지고 계셔야
돼요 언제 무슨 일이 벌어 날지
모릅니다 그리고 진짜 공실이 오랫동안
다 비어 있을 수도 있잖아요 건물이
그래서 항상 최악의 경우를 생각하고
빌딩 투자를 하셔야지 이런 리스크들을
줄일 수 있습니다 정말 옥석가리기
시장일 거 같아요 막 빌딩 시장이
엄청 살아나고 임대 시장이 되게
살아날 것처럼 보이긴 하겠지만 정말
임대 시장이 좋지 않기 때문에
여러분들이 어떻게 임대를 마칠 수
있는지 어느 정도 임대료 수준에 마칠
수 있을지를 좀 심각하게 고민해
보시고 그거 대비해서 좀 적정 수준의
대출을 받아서 빌딩 투자를 하셨으면
좋겠습니다 여러분들 제가 일단은
영상을 계속 이렇게 좀 시도하면서
많이 찍고 있거든요 좀 이런 부분을
좀 추가했으면 좋겠다 그런 부분을 좀
보완했으면 좋겠다라고 좀 댓글을 남겨
주시면 앞으로 영상 찍는데 좀 도움이
많이 될 것 같습니다 구독과 좋아요
눌러 주시면 감사하겠습니다
감사합니다 h